This episode is sponsored by hims
Your body is stunning, but have you ever wondered
About its value? Let's start selling your body
Piece with a piece. Sperm? You can get $ 35
To $ 135 for a single donation, there are banks that pay to donors
$ 1500 for a binding contract for a full year,
The criteria are to be healthy, long, young and educated.
The egg's price is much more expensive
Up to $ 10,000 is due
It has an operation spanning 20 minutes
For eggs, you may be at risk of infection or endometriosis.
The protein-rich part of your blood
Known as "plasma" and is worth $ 50
But some older rich people may pay
$ 8,000 per session until they are injected with young blood.
Although the evidence is still under study
With regard to "Fountain of Youth" or "Young Blood"
From Stanford University research where older mice were injected
Plasma placenta of a newborn human placenta
Human children have developed the performance of older mice
In the tests of the memory, no wonder!
The price of organ transplantation may be expensive
With 116,000 Americans waiting
Agriculture Member. The cost of kidney transplant is more than $ 400,000
While the price of the heart is $ 1.4 million.
This is the price of organ transplants
Not how much you will earn by selling your organs.
Although it is illegal in the United States and most countries
The black market exists. According to reports from the World Health Organization
The total cost of college in India may be $ 20,000
Up in China to $ 40,000;
But in Israel you may get $ 160,000
Do not seem interesting to you?
Try selling your hair!
The price of a wig made from real hair ranges from $ 800 to $ 3,000.
It is clear that the price of some members is high
But some people have put a price on their members.
Sources say Rianna's leg was secured
Million dollars, but not comparable to the legs of Cristiano Ronaldo
Which was insured with 144 million dollars.
Then there are the functions offered by your body.
Now you breathe, you siphon 11,000 liters a day
This means that you can blow up 275 tires.
Your thirst is 4.5 m / s
Enough wind is needed to turn on small wind turbines.
Your power is more powerful with up to 22.4 m / s
Capable of operating the air grinder unit.
Your fart? If your diet is rich in legumes
You can produce 68 ml of carbon dioxide a day.
If stored (we will not ask you why)
But if you do, within 40 years
You will have tons of carbon dioxide.
This is a huge gas quantity, but its price will be $ 220.
At the same time, your brain can store 100 terabytes of information
Hard disk space
Valued at $ 2,500.
There are components for you
Although you often consist of oxygen, carbon and hydrogen
There is evidence that there are elements that contribute to your composition
Such as copper, gold and even uranium.
However, if you add all of these items, your items may be worth the value
Close to the dollar.
Many thanks to hims for taking care of the video today
And giving our viewers a comprehensive pilot month for a $ 5 hair kit.
Hims brand provides men with high quality medical products
Of things we do not talk about sometimes
Such as sexual health, hair loss or acne.
But 26% of men with erectile dysfunction
They are under the age of forty.
Your confidentiality is treated seriously
They have good price deals on great medical products
Because they are relying on the generic product rather than the brand name.
They use personal recommendations
For prescription and non-medical products with advice from real doctors.
All you have to do is go to forhims.com/asaphair
For a virtual visit to the doctor and a free month for hair products only for $ 5.
Visit the site forhims.com/asaphair very smooth.
See you next week.
Translation: Team Etrogm @autrjim